Bob starts us out in Orlando hey Bob
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show thank
you very much I appreciate you taking my
call a pleasure to speak with you
you too sir what's up my dilemma is this
my wife and I have been married for
about 13 years now we have three
children six four and two we I guess the
bottom line is I listen to a lot of the
debt-free screams and everything and I
hear the couples talk about how
important it is to work as a team and
how it made it all come together and
they were both driving for this you know
pushing for this common goal and it
makes me really jealous honestly because
we just have a real tough time I've had
a real tough time for a long time my
wife and I you know I've always been the
financial person and she just does
whatever she needs takes care of
household expenses she's a stay-at-home
mom she purchases all the groceries and
shot general shopping and things but
I'll take care of available we're now to
a point where once we started having
kids after straitly after school what
paid off about $80,000 worth of debt in
about three years but once we started
having children you know I had to relax
a little bit because we had new expenses
I didn't know where all that was going
and it's gotten just completely out of
control over the past few years and I
are we've really reached a stalemate on
our ability to budget but I feel like
we're in a great financial position to
be extremely financially healthy but
only one I'm a one-man team and I we
seem to be finding ourselves you're
every conversation about assets just
leads to a fight and what does a fight
sound like what are one of the points
and counter points I generally I've
tried to get her to see the the overall
goal and understand financial
independence and where we want to be
when we retire and you know we want to
be broke or do we want to be in a good
financial health she doesn't get it so
I'll try to come up with budgets and say
okay well if you can just in this amount
of money a month I'll take care of the
rest I'll get get us out of debt I'll do
everything just
in X amount of dollars a month and she
just won't she just doesn't seem to
understand the value of a budget it
seems that her defense mechanisms always
pop up and they're always the same
that's you're you're bullying me you're
telling me I'm not responsible enough to
make responsible decisions financial
decisions are you you treated me like a
child
absolutely not absolutely not I don't
feel battlements earlier our family of
origin history or parents act this way
another she was raised by our
grandparents our grandfather's a farmer
and and he's warned that the same close
for 35 years but her grandmother play
the script in front over um the way I
know her grandmother was I guess her
grandmother was a bit of a spender but
she only spent on income and she was in
her she didn't make a tremendous amount
of money so it wasn't a lavish lifestyle
or anything by any means but definitely
didn't teach the teacher financial you
know understanding money well here's the
thing you guys have a communication
complete meltdown here and it's it's
beyond it's beyond a budget it's beyond
that because if that script that you're
playing for me if that routine is coming
out it's coming out in other areas too
it's not just coming out in the money I
mean because you know in other words if
you have any input on the way something
is done with a kid then she goes into
that same mode well fortunately it's
really only about money I think we are
our relationship is is very solid and
all other aspects this is we've agreed
it's not either because she it's not
either because she feels bullied when
you start talking about one thing and so
that's just that's just not true I mean
something is calling her to causing her
to fall off a hole fall off the edge
into a hole that she can't seem to get
out of in this discussion and that
that's just that's just a little weird
Bob so anyway uh not two things number
one is if I were in your shoes what
would I do
I think you guys need a tune-up on your
marriage and I would sit down with a
good marriage counselor because I think
you're probably saying things in a
hey that's activating crap inside of her
and I don't know that you do I don't
think you're doing that on purpose after
talking to you don't think there's
malice in your heart but you are you're
like me you're two things one is you're
nerdy enough and two is you're strong
enough personality and have strong
squaring off shoulders begin a backbone
that you're like to heck with that I'll
just carry it then it's easier than
dealing with all this crap and I'm just
going to go get it done and I'll just
give her an allowance and you know well
that's all we can do well that you can
do that but a you're not going to win
where you at the level you should with
money and be it's a relationship
disaster it's really going to get worse
it's not going to get better on your
relationship with this issue so I really
if I were in your shoes I would want to
sit down with her with a good marriage
counselor and say hey we got to work
through this together because I'm not
trying to bully you and I don't know why
you're hearing that and I need some help
with that and I need you to be there to
help me with that and so we're going to
sit down with a pastor we're going to
sit down with whoever you know the
counselor at the church and see if we
can begin to work through that so that's
thing one thing to more practical and
not practical but more tactical thing is
I would just go a different tact on it
and just say I'm really tired of being
the only one making the decisions and I
need your help and I need your input and
I need you to have a vote and tell me
what your goals for the future are and
how you think we ought to accomplish
them and try to get her to talk and ask
questions don't make statements and
don't ask passive-aggressive questions
that are actually statements um you know
don't ask a question like you don't you
want to you do want to retire rich don't
you you know that that's a
passive-aggressive statement so anyway
just but just ask questions and try to
get her to actually in plug in because
apparently somewhere in the process of
putting together a budget she does not
feel like her vote counts and I know you
would agree with that she about for
whatever reason she doesn't feel like
her vote counts she doesn't feel like
she has control of this scenario at all
and so she doesn't want play does that
make sense
I'm a little I guess if any right now
you know her just general shopping did a
virtual 500 or $3,000 a month that's not
gonna that's not gonna that's a symptom
that's not the problem if she has a vote
and she is one of the two adults that's
responsible for this household winning
with money and she helps define winning
with money and then she looks down and
sees that her shopping is too high she
will limit her shopping you will never
do that as an external variable an
external thing you that's got to come
from inside of her being involved in the
decision-making and then she'll look at
it and go that's ridiculous you know we
make 3500 bucks a month we can't spend
2500 shopping and I can't do that and
that's what an adult does when they look
at something now if you're dealing with
somebody who is bent on being a princess
you got another problem but I don't
think that's what's going on here so I'm
gonna say pull her into the equation
lots of questions don't bring up what
she spins ever again ask lots of
questions and pull her into the
conversation if that doesn't work and
even if it does work get a tuneup on
your marriage
you